[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
real quick uh can you go back to anna
and tommy real quick
yeah at that dedicated look at the green
team over here
we got jennifer walters and bruce banner
am i wrong that's right you got it right
i got it right first try you got it hey
i i called them ones i see them you guys
welcome to the break room welcome to the
break room welcome back you guys as we
said we were gonna hulk out today and i
had an emotionally hard week and today
it fell down and that is why i didn't
dress up as much as these two phenomenal
people i can't and yet say it enough
i think we're fine with how you dressed
up but i'm more fine with you guys you
guys turned out as someone that as
someone who loves to dress up i was like
you guys did it
off the chain you guys today we will be
talking about uh let's go up a little
bit i'm so sorry
it begins
yeah
we're gonna be talking about some things
we're gonna be talking about something
right now let me tell you about it uh
we're gonna be talking about so much
she-hulk update you guys just so much we
know this is gonna be coming you just
elba getting thirstier by the minute
oh no thank you no thank you that's not
how y'all would be thirsty y'all y'all
been asking for it
and bbw is back
a little bit of a twist a little lime
twist on that [ __ ] but it's back let me
tell you about it and uh as you see
we've already begun to hulk out yes uh
with us today is erica wussu yeah hey
internet what's happening yes yes uh
tommy beck told hey
keep it gucci to moochie keep it hulky
the bulky baby all right
you did it and my baby daddy and sharer
of an office and avastin
i'm anna banson i'm auditioning for
elphaba or spiona yes leonardo our
teenage mutant ninja turtles yeah you're
surfing alphabet way more that's what it
is it's giving elphaba
silence
i have made my decision alphabet you
stay
she-hulk sachet away oh
[ __ ] away
tens tens tens across the board speaking
of tens for every 100 we get will
actually be physically hulking out you
guys liked it when we took a little
thing out of here and we went crazy
remember when i talked about how uh true
blood just got a bad rep i'll talk more
about it i mean we did also talk about
running trains we talked about swingers
they're the hulk outs got insane so if
you want to see if they could get even
crazier somehow which given the fact
that anna's on the show seems likely
yeah
i have so much pent up anger
i'm ready oh god anger we don't need
that today you'll go crazy
they can be good you can all get an
anger if you want pokemon's all about
anger y'all caught whatever you want i
meant like i'm not ready for this desk
in our break room to pick up
today on this friday but you know what
i'm ready to demolish these headlines
as soon as anna came into the office
vortex i was like you're serving the
mask
i was told i was requested to paint my
face green amongst a rival and i got
here and no one's face was painted green
he wasn't he wasn't done up yet uh and i
felt like i got katie'd from mean girl
damn it you'd never do that also i
always uh i dress up as the joker and i
was like oh there's a chance that no one
no one is gonna dress up but i'm gonna
be the joker
so uh for those that are very excited
about the sandman netflix is the sandman
gets a surprise bonus episode that's
starring sandra oh james mcavoy and many
others uh it's those many others are
michael shannon david tennant derek
jacoby uh this is insane uh also the
fact that it hasn't been renewed yet for
a second season oh my god dude get a
bonus cowards i like that they were like
this is such a good show that we'll give
you a bonus episode but we're not ready
to renew you fully yeah
um they might have also just had that
episode in the back pocket and just
ready to just like pull it out at any
moment either way that's a star-studded
cast right there yeah um margot robbie
oh
yeah
i
i said this was break room barbie watch
with a little bit of a twist because
it's margot robbie ryan gosling yes you
are also starring in uh the barbie movie
by greta gerwig but they're starring in
the ocean's 11 prequel
double duty yeah
my microphone oh no no
we thought there couldn't be any more
numbers of oceans when we hit that new
one when they did when would this be ten
when they said ocean's eleven prequel is
confused
which one is
well there's oceans eight that's the
ladies oceans yes yes uh there's oceans
eleven twelve and yes i guess seven
there's uh there's four oceans in the
world the atlanta through the pacific
the arctic and the indian ocean will
this be a prequel to the
uh to like the george clooney ones i
guess i don't know
so much about it i thought
you know what there's oceans in between
us
emotional motion emotional god
okay i've listened to that album
emotional motion
you can get that with frank ocean idris
elba has uh teased there maybe
you know i don't do the prom thing i
know i was like i might grab it you just
have a
tease there may be something cooking up
regarding heimdall's potential future in
the mcu what is wrong with him he works
on everything we get it i want don't get
me wrong camera four
never already bear i want him on
everything i want him on every movie i
wanted to play all the characters that
he played i wanted to play new
characters in the mcu
but he doesn't got to convince us
all he has to do is show up
have his have his manager call
say when do you need my guy there he
shows up we're happy but you know what
it gives us content and it gives us an
excuse to go
oh thirsty
play the graphic oh and everybody's
walking
around just
yeah sorry i figured we needed that hey
guys little behind the scenes here
it's friday night and i just got paid i
did two songs
don't pay attention to him taping my
microphone but john is in the break room
he's touching my butt now
i wish we could still drink on this show
what do you think i'm doing over here oh
you got a bedello there you go
don't get drunk
to add on to this for a little bit oh
yeah tgif babies to add to this for a
little bit uh he basically was in that
interview and he was like i just love
heimdall and i would love to have him
come back he wasn't really like it is
thirsty don't get me wrong your
character's dead yeah
yeah oh there it is
we're reaching out soon we've got we've
got some big updates in the cemu to the
break room uh thing let's put it this
way we've got we've got an end with simu
we've got a contact we're going to be
getting trying to get a hold of steve
we'll see if we can make this work out
i've never seen that graphic that is
genuinely terrifying
they're like haunting puppets
i don't like it
so uh she-hulk you guys was rejected
from the avengers
how dare they i know
already
immediately rejected one of the things
that happened in she-hulk uh is oh this
is from jessica gao by the way creator
head writer for sheila she says one of
the things that happened in she-hulk is
there are all these things that are said
some of which are germaine to her living
in the world and these would be things
that are said uh she revealed that but
there is that scene outside the prison
where she goes scroll
down
she
but there's a scene outside the prison
where she goes to see abomination and
the reports the reports like we heard
she's been rejected from the avengers
it's like whispered behind her i would
be shocked if she uh if they didn't
start putting her in the movies
especially the group team-up movies i
think that's insane that they it's
because it could be rumored
it's cmc it's just rumor there's a
chance that like maybe she has been she
wasn't accepted avengers but i don't
think it seems like it happened so quick
the last thing on her play was to apply
to be an avenger well and mark ruffalo
had just had that quote the other day
where he's like oh there won't be
another avengers movie without she-hulk
so
it's conflicting
well i think it's just fun i think it's
gonna be added fun for she-hulk because
it's just like uh it's like she doesn't
want to be an avenger a b
who are the avengers right now who do
you mean that she got turned down turn
around by who we don't know where anyone
is
the world in the mcu acts like the
avengers is this like boy band yeah
it's always got somebody in it and
someone's always pulling the strings and
people get rejected people apply but i
think it's just this is a hodgepodge of
people sometimes and when a thanos level
event happens the avengers kind of
assemble and bring them in yeah but
they're not like a fan club we're crying
a lot people are in and out of all this
i see i see in the chat people are
saying that i look like i'm sweating the
makeup is fresh guys okay i threw this
on 10 minutes before a very busy day i'm
a very important man okay and i did this
for you
and which is really unfair because you
guys do nothing for me your garbage
all you do is you drain my life you come
here you ask your little cute questions
want me to answer them listen trash bags
i put on 18 pounds of green makeup now i
look like shrek
is having a heart attack okay it doesn't
feel good it doesn't feel good it
doesn't look good so be nice in your
comments and by the way this isn't a
hulk grant this is a bulk grant okay
this is me just ranting i know you guys
want to see
ranta you've been been referred to as
rana ranta
which we'll do
17 away well we got there hey
so you know i think you were on yeah you
were on for the whole brand when we did
grab the whole friends we were like
crazy but we did our whole voices yeah
yeah absolutely but i think i don't
think we need to pull i think we just
give it to you i think we give it to you
people want to see anna do it we already
have to do it
okay no i'm saying
no sorry
we don't need to pull the chat we're
giving it to anna gotcha no it's not
it's real it's sorry i heard it but i
have this mic
okay okay sorry all right
it's a very real microphone it costs
lots of money oh this is so vague it
says hulk out on a movie
is it vague or is it an opportunity for
anything to happen i like i like the
smart hole but it's feasible
name some movies i can't think of okay
uh top gun
redemption the sand lot uh
this is a hulk hogan i'm doing that
that's fine
let me tell you about elvis brother
now listen austin butler brother did a
really good job as elvis but the movie
was just joining brother oh
it was also two hours and 40 minutes
long
i got out of that movie theater at 1 30
a.m that's too late brother even though
i'm kind of a night owl why didn't you
see elvis that late elvis is a 7 p.m
movie my friends i was by myself
oh my god who's not taking anna to
movies what's wrong with you uh listen i
uh what else
could we
how do you do it um
elvis was okay i would just maybe not
see it in theaters just wait for it to
come out but austin butler was great so
good job on you buddy if you're seeing
it
back in the chat says tommy named seven
movies four of which were pornos
that is true thank you zach i love you
zach thank you thank you sorry we didn't
get a thousand dollars yesterday and
your child remains unbaptized
all right oh my god maybe today yeah oh
yeah guys if we raise a thousand dollars
today i'll baptize ten babies next year
you guys have to give us the babies yeah
uh baby's not included it's really
dangerous actually whoever is offering
the babies yeah i used to be a lifeguard
i can handle it i'm your baby so does
that count i will baptize you whenever
you want
beautiful you guys you know what else is
beautiful
she hulk uh and anna she hulk tatiana
maslany uh teases how big the upcoming
cameo was the greatest moment of her
life you guys this is the next episode
coming in so episode number two uh she
says it was the greatest moment of my
life muslim four three three or four is
it three or four wouldn't it be she is
she talking about dance the dance
also yeah we wouldn't know if we didn't
see it but i'm gonna say this right now
uh anna's our researcher and also finds
us the best headlines for the break room
so she is backing me up because she
knows exactly what i'm talking about i i
can't say if it's three or four because
i kind of have right but i'm just like
oh no i mean it's one of them oh jesus
uh well she starts with saying
he's roll up a little bit yeah i'm sorry
sorry
uh she says it was the greatest moment
of my life maslany explains adding that
having to do it as uh she-hulk wasn't at
all a dampener especially in the mocap
suit there's no way i'm going to feel
cool if i'm opposite the most beautiful
cool person on the planet there's just
no way so if i can look like a little
kid dancing in pajamas that's fine with
me as long as i get to dance with her
i'm happy so there's going to be a dance
scene there's going to be a dancing but
she never says who it is do we have
guesses i feel like it's the last person
on the coolest most beautiful person on
earth and it's a her oh it's not one
is it angelina jolie is it athena oh
that would be fun
maybe it is titania you got me hooked on
wong now i would kill you she's like
she's the best dancer everyone comes out
with like a freaking fan they do the
pulp fiction dance together
the twists it couldn't be a jamilah's
character
it could be because in the comics
they're friends um titanium is friends
with like literally everyone in the
comics but later on in the newer season
or the newer runs of uh she hulk she
just basically is like
i'm too old for this [ __ ] like she just
was like why are we fighting if you want
to fight we can just go spar in a gym
and that's what she does with titania in
texas
is married with a child and it's like
yeah this is better for my schedule
it's much more fun
i wish my enemies would just
settle down and meet me in a gym rather
than the streets you have to clean up
the boat in the streets i'm so sick of
these streets
but i was made for him
[Laughter]
oh if it's elena i'd cry i would lose my
mind producer john and i would both like
elena to be there we have crushes on
jessica
yeah
she broke up with zach brad
in character in canon i'm sure
coming through
another poll happy friday to you you are
always there for us between you and
graveyard we have some really great bags
of trash
i'm gonna start calling you guys my bin
buds or something like that i'm not
trying to sway the polls or anything but
i would love to see just rant today
because i feel like she could use just
like i think every
i don't know about eric eric you seem
like pretty in a pretty good place any
one of us would be happy to rant this
week after the week that we've had john
may have to come in here honestly i do
think if if all four of us get to rant
in the show we're gonna let john do the
fifth one because he's had a week as
well and he needs to rant we might let
hank rant
yeah
he's just gonna lick the mic do the
people know who hank is oh no oh okay
hank was at the hot dog hosted one week
uh she-hulk creator uh jessica reveals
marvel studios had full control over the
daredevil look usually how they do it is
they kind of let us propose what we want
to do rather than give us guidelines got
revealed when they first told us that
the possibility we could we just
couldn't believe it and as we were
coming up with the story and we wanted
him to do and what we wanted him to do
the fact that they kept not saying no
was shocking to us the one thing they
didn't have control of was the suit they
knew exactly what they wanted the suit
to look like which is pretty
i think this is a big deal because it's
like uh and born again he didn't really
get that well we got the outfit from
someone else we got it from a fake
daredevil in season three so now we're
getting like the the fresher suit coming
over to the mcu like disney's mcu so
kevin feige was like nah if we're gonna
make it different we're gonna put him in
the comic accurately
and i just i'm like damn that meant a
lot to you guys i love how every
interview i read with jessica gao she's
so she's like fan girls she's so pumped
for every right they were able to get so
she's like we could do dear denim
joking she said the little thing about
spiderman she's so cute i also love that
she's just like open about it yeah i
feel like michael waldron was like well
i have another property that i'm
probably going to write on so i'm not
going to give away too much just kidding
i was like i've been trying to get
she-hulk on the screen for six years and
i said no
86 years
yeah you love when the creators are fans
of the of the material you know that
makes just for a better product and a
better
you know set and show and writer's room
all that good stuff so we love to see it
100
so
the show creator jessica gow revealed
that uh charlie cox wasn't originally in
the show but was added to it after he
closed the deal to return for no way
home and daredevil again
and that's a two-man that's two-man deal
you know the intro and the fool's outro
he's like now i'm going to be on
everything
i'm so excited for daredevil born again
jess you've got the rant
well jessica's working on iran let's
talk about some polls that we have did
you guys watch sandman yet a lot of you
saying no but a lot of you begging us to
cover it on this show so that poll
better go up all right that poll better
rise to the occasion now who's the best
dancer in the mcu we all know it's zemo
come on that was not even a question and
then it's star lord do you think will be
an avenger by the end of season one wow
i like the urgency on that 51 say yes
close close close questions
all right jess what do you got okay i'm
not going to tell you guys what it is
i'm going to just go off
oh hulk love fast food
fast food's so great and honestly it
gets a bad breath yeah it stops your
heart eventually but i'm 28 i have time
i love mcdonald's and i'll eat a double
quarter pounder whenever i feel
i don't understand what people's hype oh
wait i forgot i live in l.a and they
hate fast food but i love it unless
we're talking in and out that shit's
trash oh i do not like in and out
you have to put a condiment on something
for it that tastes good it's not good
and not talking about their animal frog
we're talking taco bell i'm only getting
the party pack 13 tacos because i eat
all of them in one evening
carl's jr i don't eat uh because there's
not one close to my house but when i was
a child i ate the greasiest sandwich
from there and then i went to five guys
and realized they're better and they
have peanuts tommies tommy's tommy's
burger do they have the goop because
that's what i love yeah i mean
everybody's a little more satisfied with
some tommy's inside them i don't know
what
i'm trying to scrape off the goop i've
had me millions of times and i love it
i'll never stop asking for a tommy and
camera four please
if i had to rate my fast food joints
i'll be honest burger king's first whoa
burger king's birthday oh macdonald shut
the stream up spicy nuggets jack in the
box comes in fourth and i'm putting five
guys that's my where's wendy's wendy's
is my third oh okay sure i was too
shocked
burger king fries and the whopper's the
greatest thing and you don't need to put
mayonnaise on it okay folks we've had a
lot of fun here today but the cheesy
gordita crunch is oh yeah taco bell i
don't know i don't think there's a lot
of pizza you're eating 13 tacos i can't
eat 13 gordita crunches but that's 13
tacos that's true blessings
[Laughter]
all right well guys that was another
great hulk grant we're just 76 away from
another rant it's friday
go ahead and hit us with some super
chats people are
a lot of praise for anna and the super
chats we appreciate that carla giving
generously to hear anna's rant justin
quinn gao said episode one fast
flashbacks would be originally for
episode eight does that mean cicar
connections won't be addressed until
episode eight or nine or final credits
frown face i don't know i hope they
bring it up sooner mr suave asks is
there any reason in particular you're
wearing a cap shirt today i mean
yesterday's discussion was talking about
uh you know like the captain not being a
virgin so i just thought i'd
share the love today with my shirt as a
she-hulk you know you know why thanks
thanks for having me also archer um i
know this this mic is hot i don't know
what you're talking about
oh for our last headline uh cat's out
the bag you guys jamila jamil injured
her [ __ ] while filming in shield uh
it's been rumored what it could have
been that she injured but we know she
didn't want to say it and in the
interview she said uh like you'll
probably have to bleep this out but i
pulled a muscle in my [ __ ] she goes
on to say i didn't even know that was
possible yeah she should have asked me i
could tell you what happens all the time
i'm trying to figure out what position
like what gets them well if you fall
really hard really hard and you're like
in a open because a lot of her stunts
are getting pulled on a rope or like you
know midair so maybe she fell off oh a
harness too could have maybe cracked
cracked in there and pull you know the
wrestler x-pock famously giving his
bronco buster
finisher uh ripped ripped his butt uh
part uh it completely apart and no
stopping i never had to go to the
emergency room but finish the match
finish the match that's a that's a
warrior right there that's it the show
must go on they don't make them like
that even if the hole is no longer there
and it's more of a it's more of a canyon
the show must go on who fights a guy
with a torn booty hole that's just i'm
just saying someone in an american
legion somewhere in front of fifteen
people would be like i know
as i'm saying most women that give birth
tear from their v to their so they're
all
i
can't wait to be a dad anyway
uh that was great let's let's start
let's go into a discussion here guys
and guess what your boy's leading the
discussion which means it's going to be
incoherent and tough to follow
i'll handle my own please thank you i
love you
sometimes you just got to do it solo
oh i didn't like where that was going
not including me that's a whole word
please cut to just his camera
uh you know what guys i don't feel the
support that i need to keep doing the
show now
listen to me
rumor has that the mcu is planning a
phase for mutant movies just an entire
phase which i think makes sense
that's right we can play the whole song
i don't know what instruments are anyway
devon faracci in an article with the
direct said the reason why is its
contractual situation with the original
fox stuff is going to be in effect till
2025. we may not even have an earth to
have movies on by then so if they don't
want to use those actors
then they have to wait until all the
contract all expires he went on to
mention that we'd see mutants in phase
seven now that to me sounds like some
that to negotiating sounds like there's
some actors that are going to be bought
out of their contracts and some actors
are going to be brought back
into uh into those roles are there
characters you think going to be
attached to the role so it's like you
can't use rogue yet because i think that
they will i mean who is rogue right now
in fox it's anna paquin right right i
think the conversation goes something
like this anna paquin your career is
going great you have like multiple tv
shows that you're either a regular or a
recurring guest star on if we gave you
five hundred thousand dollars can we
recast the role of rogue which is
nothing to them that's a lot to us but
none of them and here's what aaron
pakman says no no she says sure great
fine no problem i don't want to do that
anymore it was 20 years of my life well
if if it's anna pacquin but then you
might get someone that's not in a pack
when this well then you cast a new rogue
and you move on with your freaking line
that's another anna i see you go look at
that
you could go rogue any day now that is
true you should be an x-men yeah you'd
be a good accident
if we were all x-men who would we be um
i'd be morph
oh don't look so upset
he dies in the pilot
i'd probably be yeah i'd probably be
darwin and die in the first oh god let's
all be the bad better imaginations for
yourselves guys
please pick up the positivity nice
question i'd be nightcrawler yeah i'd be
colossus but i have a question does
colossus go titanium everything or
whatever he's made out of i don't think
like this like what if he accidentally
colossizes while he's getting me going
that's what happened as soon as you
looked down as you were saying that i
was like oh no yeah i'm just saying it's
like it looks like uh like um like a
linoleum like a garage door you don't
want that ah i mean i got enough stuff
going down there
right now that needs to be taken care of
i can't really add problems all right so
sounds like we'd be getting an after
secret wars how do we feel about this we
want mutants sooner right i want them
for secret wars yeah but if they're if
they're planning to come after singapore
that means we're gonna get introduced to
so many other mcu characters before
secret wars maybe secret war starts like
once the planet like disperses maybe
we'll go into there's mutants now right
or doom starts the mutants i yeah i feel
like that
like i mean if we're to take that
rumor seriously that they they can't
have mutants until 2025 what that means
is they right now can't have them until
2025. but we all know because we rented
apartments in college contracts were
made to be shattered
i love going after a contract and just
going back on it and people threatening
lawsuits nothing gets my blood going
faster than knowing that i'm in breach
of contract i'm smoking like a true
red-blooded american that's right i got
rats it could also be a marvel mutant
yeah that's what i was on this side i
was like yeah we're already starting
those ones so maybe what the x-men
because they're familiar they're not
making these shows for me
[Music]
zach is toad no zach could be like
cyclops
or he'd be um what was channing tatum
want to be yeah
i think brandon would be more branded
again
i'm gonna go uh i'm gonna actually i'm
gonna be like that guy uh lion raised
lions not sheeps who had to pay a bunch
of extra money because his goods were
made in china and he put made in america
tags on them i'm gonna say raise
colossus's not morphs those would be my
hats oh i like that
a shirt i'll probably just end up being
storm it's free to make free uh
all right
so you talked about this kind of you
guys said we have other we have
kamal we have other mutants that don't
have to necessarily be
uh x-men so we could get those earlier
do you think it's more likely that we
get them all at one time or we're going
to like introduce some marvel mutants i
think we're going to do marvel mutants
yeah i think they'll get introduced
property by property that's my armpit
property by property we're going to get
you know we got carmilla as a mutant at
the end of miss marvel i think in each
day and then there's the kind of maybe
little
glossed over thing that bruce said in
the first episode of um she-hulk whereas
he was like our dna just like kind of do
you think she's what you think she is
she i mean it might be revealed like if
they did further into it you know be
insane as she is a mutant and then his
blood changed everything about her being
a mutant and that was triggered or
triggered it yeah yeah that's the thing
is like that opens a million
that might be why he dramatically
destroyed the vials of blood with the
red lasers
what if her blood was the essence to the
terrigen mist that would have like
killed a bunch of people
but um i like that by the way i'm
reading the chat everybody knows that
vos would be squirrel girl okay oh yeah
and like awesome never notch knocker i
see you baby garbage plates are way
better than fast food nick tahoe's king
of the garbage please it's a garbage
place it's a rochester delicacy and
honestly i think one day on the show i
should make you all garbage plates what
is the consistency it's the it's the
signature dish of western new york it's
macaroni salad home fries
two burgers or two hot dogs on top
chili or meat sauce not chili a meat
sauce
onions mustard you dip some bread in it
that's insane you it's listen it's a
it's a heart stopper you don't do it a
lot
but you do do it at least a few times
when you do it you do it hard that's
right
that's right i like how it's all covered
in a meat sauce it's so good i'm sorry
if you if you've had it if you've been
there you know and if not same reactions
from most people whenever you tell
anyone from outside of rochester about
garbage plates so like are you kidding
me i mean i've made a couple of
california luthers in my day
yeah i did two krispy kreme donuts and i
get a flying dutchman from in and out
because they sell that to you and then i
put them together and then the donuts
are the bun and i eat that and my
heart's and then i come out of nowhere
and i go come on
she knows when i'm doing it she can just
feel it oh keith's woodcrest from
irondequoit my mom was born in iran at
corey all right stand up all right
all right this is a very food heavy show
yeah what's your friend sorry real quick
before we get back to the discussion
what's a flying dutchman
it's just uh two patties and cheese oh i
like that yeah no bread no anything they
just sell that to you in a box that's
like a flying dutchman all right
so we got film series and films in
series we could see mutants show up and
we got deadpool 3 seems like a natural
what other what other series i could i
don't know like looking at the ones that
have come out loki makes sense right
well i think oh yes i also think that uh
going off of what uh eric said saying
that jen might be immune i think monica
is still a mutant oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
so i think there is like a ton that are
now
uh being introduced that have already
been there
but i feel like yeah we'll we'll
definitely get into it level up gaming
no nick tahoe slander but dog town is
delicious all right everybody knows
empire hops and webster is also a
classic these are all free
advertisements for restaurants no we're
not being paid at all
yeah my wolverine senses are tingling i
feel like there's always a wolverine
just around the corner
i am so
this is me being jessica and i'll be
honest with you guys i'll be real i am
good without a logan
for a little while for a little while
especially for for a while
except for an x-men 97. i don't mind
animated actually coming in that's a
different story but for movies if they
were like yeah we pulled him back in and
i'd be like oh my gosh dude i just saw
his last movie yeah
18 years 18 years we've had a wolverine
yeah from the x-men uh
it wasn't him
so what other so let's go disney plus
specifically anna said this song is not
for me you didn't want to launch the
whole course
while you're at it
i think that would really take us into a
new direction on this show that i hadn't
planned on but uh we get a whole
different fan base so let's just go
through the disney plus series like you
guys say yay or nay moon night mutants
no no moon nights no mutants in
moonlight uh
some sort of hawkeye uh
cake cake bishop uh oh yes
uh yeah i can see it because i think in
new york that's probably where it's
going to spawn and i think it's uh what
better movie than that okay or a show to
come in then
all right so we've all had these
theories i think
what about all that i get the show
coming out oh
sure how's it going i don't think that
means think they're more sorcerers and
that is the magic phase i like what
you're saying but like i think if we're
gonna have a mutant face we do have the
magic face but why not have the mutants
to be magical
all right so real quick as we wrap this
up how do you guys think these mutants
are going to be introduced into the mcu
when do you think i think it will be at
the end i think i believe a phase seven
probably after secret war something big
does happen which it like triggers a lot
like even if it is like yeah while we
were on battle world i created this like
terrigen mist and like i've gotta just
create a bunch of people or doom brings
a lot of more people into play i think
that makes sense sure first movie after
this
does an after credit scene count as an
introduction yeah oh yeah okay it's
going to be in an after credit scene
like it's coming great yeah i still
think like in every release or maybe
every other release we get yeah because
we got something at the end of ms marvel
but we didn't get anything mutant
related at the end of thor four or yeah
so i think every other every couple mcu
releases they'll just like sprinkle in a
little bit of more mutant breadcrumb a
little further development on the train
i like that yeah i think i i think i i
think i i'm on a similar wavelength is
you on that eric uh
and speaking of similar wavelengths
we want to shout out our friends at the
epic hero merch shop
they just released their green justice
merch line inspired by the jolly green
goddess herself she-hulk it's got
several different t-shirt designs
including the newest limited edition
latest obsession shirt lady justice and
when you purchase that shirt
you trigger an emotional response from
us financially uh and you also uh
introduced the opportunity to get a
custom shout out for one of our fine
marvel hosts eric voss mt with the
lovely
jessica clemens
who's doing all the breakdowns and those
breakdowns are soaring on this channel
looks like jessica's got a gift
we're also dropping lines uh inspired by
house of the dragon andor riverdale
adventure time uh the amazing world of
gumball uh just bart simpson and rings
of power in the coming weeks and only
three of those are real you have to
guess oh
teleprompter we're doing inventions full
house
uh fuller house
uh we have a balky perfect stranger's
shirt coming out
yeah we have a eddie munson right we
have an eddie munson coffin uh all right
now
did that correct that john
got his ass i've never heard him
all right what do we got 50 more bucks i
want to do some more hulk grants guys
please i can't do them unless you give
to the super chat john won't let me
sometimes i'm like let me just do one
and john threatens us
but you know what he can't do he can't
stop this fresh face from promoting
geology this is another fresh face
friday brought to you by our friends at
geology who we are so grateful for for
sponsoring the break room this week
we're shining the spotlight on a fresh
face in the mcu and that would be
another no that would be none other than
she-hulk herself tatiana
oh god she's wonderful isn't she she
recently appeared as the religious
prophet sister alice mckegan on the hbo
reboot of perry mason which i auditioned
for 10 times and did not book ah but
many of you know her from her
emmy-winning work on orphan black and
perry mason if you're gonna do another
season you better hire my ass when she
played 14 different clone versions of
herself that's incredible i thought for
sure she was british in real life turns
out she's american ah that's a lot of
faces i should read the whole sentence
before i say my own thing
however she was green with all the envy
and all the other actors getting to join
the mcu and get those sweet discounts to
disney front of the line passes but now
she can proudly join the ranks of mcu
heroes as the fresh green face of
justice and we have to play that many
faces you want to make sure they all
look smooth healthy and hydrated if you
want to keep your face it's fresh
looking at she-hulk check out the great
skincare products at geology
you can take a quick quiz at geology.com
new rockstars and they'll suggest the
perfect lineup of skincare items
head to geology.com
new rockstars and use our promo code
rockstar 70 to save 70 percent off 70 on
a 30-day drop 70 70. 70. that's not a
typo 70 off on a 30-day trial that's
what we gotta read so let me ask you one
more time you said 70s
what you're saying i'm hearing this
all right we got a rant we got a yeah
we're going for a rant but what i'm
pulling for right now is a little fun
mandatory fun
thank you ricardo martinez for the 50
yes thank you
no it's important to thank our
supporters now
mandatory fund is the most popular
segment in the world i think uh by all
analytics according to youtube every
time we do mandatory fun we immediately
receive a 5 000 increase in viewership
it's where i gather my three best
friends in the whole world together to
have a little non-optional fun with me
guys do you want me to get brandon
should i go again
you're my best friend now
all right brandon
you guys are all my sweet sweet friends
my tom squad uh today's mandatory fun
really celebrates hookup culture which i
celebrate every week if you know what
i'm saying hey
so uh we also we heard recently thank
you uh
uh i am going to do my hulk grant after
i explain mandatory fund and then we'll
get into the mandatory fund so she all
actually created a profile on tinder
for jennifer walters right
as part of a promotion by the way if i
thought that i was matching with tatiana
tiana
tatiana maslany and then it turned out
it was an ad for she-hulk i would be
like that makes sense because this
didn't make sense before but i'd also be
very upset okay i'd be very pissed off
so anyway turn this upside down jessica
and i are gonna have eric and anna play
a little game of guess the mcu tinder
person okay are we swiping too
well you could decide if you want to
swipe right or left if you guessed them
correctly but if you don't guess them
correctly it's a little swipe it's a
love match gone i love that we're like
the host of like a dating channel yeah
also i just
so that's why i'll be on my phone and
philip molina texted me and we're
talking about i was like it's been a
minute since i talked to you are you
doing and he was like i'm finishing this
roof and i'm having a really hard time
do you want to help and i'm not going to
respond
oh we got the white boards out that's
fun all right
it's time to hulk out
hulk out on college
home went to college
three different colleges
four times no degrees
first hulk go to private jesuit college
thinking hulk played football
hulk quick football team after coach no
no hulk's name
no say who are you hulk's name written
on front of helmet like all other
players hulk's feelings very hurt shout
out to coach for that hulk then go to
suny oswego
alumni alma mater of jerry seinfeld al
roker linda cohn from sportscenter the
woman who played martha huber on
desperate housewives steve levy
a cousin sale from jimmy kimmel and hulk
himself what did you study hulk hulk
studied special education uh and what
hulk thought would be teacher promising
career with good lifestyle instead hulk
become actor and borrow money from
parents at all three colleges hulk got
thrown out of third second college
for hulk drinking too much hulk had to
go to monroe community college and
recover his reputation with both his
parents and the eyes of these new york
school system yes so how much i learned
from she-hulk that it takes a lot for
you guys to get drunk you've gone
through like 40 bottles in one night so
how much were you going through
really like jenny light hulk like jenny
light humped like jenny cremail hulk
like natural light hulk fight
milwaukee's best in something known as
best chest 30 beers hulk drink all of
them hulk drink hurricane floridies hope
then go to mcc stop drinking for a while
lose weight get girlfriend hulk gets
back into oswego break up with
girlfriend gain weight back start
drinking again no no hold on hold don't
graduate hulk drives to new york or
california and chevy cavalier hulkby's
failed actor for 15 years find himself
doing youtube at 40. hulk cries more
than he laughs
hope hulk cries himself to sleep every
night
oh cry
hulk i love you just the way you are oh
thanks
[Applause]
that was that was just that wasn't me
obviously hulk was that was just a
character that i did and not
autobiographical at all not in the
slightest well it's mandatory fun right
yeah
play the grammy yes
all right
like i said ah the storm virgil did i
make you uncomfortable
hulk needs 420. hulk wishes he could use
420 420 do nothing to hulk
i'll need to go up and hulk need to
drink all right so tinder profile i'll
go first we can
yeah yeah we'll go back and forth so i'm
gonna give you guys
parts of this person's uh tinder profile
uh and you have to guess which mcu
character it is okay okay
so
this person said i'm a grower not a
shower i'm great at following orders
and i've got an inner freak just waiting
to burst out inside of me
there's a few people this could be
freaky
yeah freak there's an inner freak just
waiting to burst out i mean i'm going
with like what i think would be the most
obvious
you guys ready yeah yeah all right guess
it
turn around oh
that's a good guess the answer though
was abomination
wow
the key was following orders abomination
of course following orders turned him
into abomination i don't get to [ __ ]
hole damn sorry guys maybe next time
no thanks i'll catch
you guys you're on you're on tinder
you're on tinder right yeah
22. vigilante
uh for school dropout but they put the
peace sign emoji whoa
honestly my mom just wanted me on this
something about prioritizing my time i
don't think i'll have time to really go
on dates dress up and play girlfriend
but if you're into fighting crime call
me maybe better yet just come find me
hmm
who is this
i was thinking male the entire time
until you said she and then i was like
[ __ ] i'm thinking the wrong way i'm
sorry i'm swearing a lot it's not we
don't have the swear jar redemption
anymore i'm free yeah you're free wait
one more time really quick okay 22
vigilante dropout honestly my mom just
wanted me on uh wanted me on this
something about prioritizing my time i
don't think i'll have time really to go
on dates dress up and play girlfriend
but if you're really into fighting crime
call me maybe better yet just come find
me
i got it
do you have it
this is wrong but this is my best guess
okay ready turn around what do you think
are you ready ready um uh what's what's
the [ __ ] um
thank you
yeah i mean it's not right pointed out
oh god
i think
some of you guys in the chat got it yeah
it is kate bishop yeah empty
i knew it was kate bishop all right good
job good job chad
these are good immediately
uh this is uh this is the next one
sometimes
i'm not much for small talk
i love working with a group or colony
but i'm also not afraid to do things
solo i'm a convicted felon with a heart
of gold
hmm
colony
what if i guess three people wouldn't
that be fun that'd be great
don't act like that uh cricket wasn't
hot that was a hot ass cricket
an evil it wasn't michael shannon
it might have like
yes beloved actor kevin spacey
never done anything wrong
this is a different multiverse
can you turn your things around who is
it um
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so it's one to nothing so far
there is mine is 26.
26. wow you did their ages yeah special
agent
unconfirmed for school hello i'm
recently single the boy i loved died i
will never be over him and i can kill
you easily
nah
hello i'm recently single the boy i love
died i will
and i can kill you easily
oh my god i'm swiping right
are you ready this is wrong but yeah
let's go this is a pete wheeler black
widow none of y'all both have chicken
pox
who does she love that died
the boy i love died and never quit oh no
she died and clinton didn't eat that
that's wrong and also her love interest
was bruised spanish
and he never died she went to the next
one all right
my final one
i'm not picky i love fancy dinners or
just staying home eating mac and cheese
family is very important to me
and fellas i'm bilingual
bilingual
that was unbilingual is that is
if you said sharon i'll still give it to
you for peggy because it's like this
i'm not picky i love a fancy dinner or
just staying home eating mac and cheese
family is very important to me
is that i'm bilingual mac and cheese
yes it's delicious it is delicious i
love maggots i make a really good mac
and cheese all right one two three oh it
is oh i'm stupid
i heard family and thought vin diesel
and fast and furious oh well yeah but
she cared a lot about her family and she
remember she broke into kate bishop's uh
yes uh
49 occupation number one fighter
school what's a school
i don't know what this is i don't need a
mate i was already mated i seek
destruction i'm attractive but you're
probably ugly whoa oh [ __ ] i swipe right
baby
is who i need uh keep me humble i don't
know what this is i don't need a mate i
was already made it i seek destruction
i'm attractive but you're probably ugly
oh
i think i got it
number one fighter what's a school
49 is what's throwing me yes
did any of them go to school
it's a hero or a male 1 um
you could say both
but i
[Laughter]
is
neither of you did good
hit the graphic again
this
[Music]
i'm just
kidding uh all right well well we don't
have time to talk about andor today
unfortunately so
we are gonna have to say goodbye and
good weekend uh did we do a clip of the
week this week or did that fall through
okay listen guys like i said not
everything goes as planned sometimes
life throws you 64 doctor's appointments
in one week sometimes your car says oh
just put some coolant in it'll be fine
and then all of a sudden your dashboard
goes crazy and tells you that the
computers have taken over the ai's
trying to kill you all right and you
just don't get to do a clip of the week
so maybe next week we'll do two clips if
you're good okay that's all for the
break room today i want to thank
everybody for doing the show thank you
to anna thank you to eric for stepping
in thank you to jessica for being my
moon stars
love of my life thank you to all of you
for watching from your dumpsters
your back alleyways and your pee stained
mattresses that are out on the street i
appreciate all of you thank you all of
our super chatters and our thank you to
our mods thank you to john for producing
thank you to dodson for taking care of
the super chats and all the poll
questions reminder you can leave us a
voicemail on the discord and again next
week we'll be back with a clip of the
week let's take it out with a hulk grant
yeah and we have the tiki takis yes and
we're on tick tock at the underscore
break room hulk don't get cryptocurrency
hulk don't get nfts why not just invest
money in real companies why not just
open savings account with high yield why
not buy property and rent property hulk
understand passive income hulk no
understand horse with cigarette and
mouth as art form hulk don't kick girl
moving around jacuzzi as painting hope
think cryptocurrency and nft stupid but
hulk think you smart hulk say goodbye
[Music]
you